florence pugh goes braless in a sheer
gown at valentino runway free the
[ __ ] nipple she says there we go okay
we're gonna show some pictures of it too
the 26 year old carried herself with
complete confidence not using any sort
of undergarment to cover her nipples
which were left visible under the bright
fabric
i was excited to wear it are we not
allowed to show it oh yeah here we go i
was excited to wear it not a wink of me
was nervous i wasn't before during or
even now after it isn't the first time
it certainly won't be the last time a
woman will hear what's wrong with her
body by a crowd of strangers okay i love
when women say this they're like
everyone's weighing in on my boob you
put the boobies out there of course
people gonna comment on them people
comment about everything they're gonna
someone's gonna tell me they hate my
shirt someone's gonna tell me they don't
like my bun everybody comments about
everything but here's my problem with
this
women need you got to just save
something you got to save something for
your partner for behind closed doors
there's nothing sexier to me sometimes
than a woman who's buttoned up who's a
little buttoned up you know beautiful
does the hair and makeup like looks all
but he's buttoned up i feel like women
like there's nothing left to the
imagination you put the nipples out
there what's left really i mean we know
what's left that's coming soon too it's
going to be like oh look clear down too
let me get this straight are you saying
you're not a fan of the phrase i'm
saying i i just like listen if
i have nipples they pop out every now
and then i mean it happens right hold on
what we just find out that jedi has
listen let's break some new scenes i've
got nipples
yeah i've got nipples you milk me [ __ ]
i am a woman
breaking news i have nipples you're
identifying as a woman or you are a lot
well both i'm an idiot no i identify i
heard tell jim a woman identifies a cat
how many times i got to tell you
do you think as a man as a man do you
appreciate a woman who
like do you want to see it all out there
like that is that appealing to you or do
you appreciate a woman who saves a
little bit doesn't show the whole world
and that's special for you because
they've chosen you and you go home at
night and you get to see what everybody
else doesn't get to see genuinely
curious yeah fair question uh
what the young girl was wearing with
sort of pseudo nipples out there
more power to you however
um i kind of agree with you on this one
i think like i'm not saying i want a
girl wearing like a like a none outfit
buttoned up i mean let's not get crazy
here let's not go to you know like i'm
not trying to have like a put uh like
we're going to the middle east and
putting like a whole thing breaking news
adam's not attracted to nuns no or uh
hijab okay um
but yeah i think that there should be a
fine line between like looking sexy and
attractive
but also like saving a little something
for
you know for the man in the bedroom or
whatever you got going on so
don't put it all out there like there's
girls in south beach that run out with
i mean they're free and everything like
everything's free yeah and at some point
it's like
clean it up a little bit do you know why
some women do that though adam i have to
tell you
because they want to look now they want
to feel good about themselves because
there is a segment of the one female
population that wants to that that wants
to be desired right they want they're
like what you described before about
people who are like out there and
they're like putting it out there for
somebody else and what happens is
women
if they if they if they dress sexy
but they're not trashy what happens is
they go on a date with a guy and then
some girl that's putting it all out
there walks down the street and and that
guy who spent the last two hours telling
their girlfriend you know what i love
that you just look sexy and classy i
love classy watch as that trashy looking
girl walked downstream and goes
so the lesson for that woman is oh wait
a minute he's telling me he likes one
thing but he doesn't
can you explain that to me is that just
guys is that just guys like you see
something like a cheeseburger and you're
like
or is that really like you're lying to
women and you really
really
want to look at all the goods out there
but you don't want it for your woman
because you don't want other guys seeing
their goods like what's going on here
tell me the psychology of it you want me
to reveal i want women how men think yes
that's right if you're on jedi be alive
this is not sauce cast that's true i
don't
well i this might be this might upset
some of the viewers but it's possible
for a guy to be super attractive and
maybe even in love with this woman right
here
but if some smoke show walks by he might
want to do this
and kind of like what you said about
the
good guy that walks in a room and makes
eye contact with a couple women at the
bar
and goes in beelines over at his woman
same concept
like but you don't want your
is there something to be said like you
want your woman classy
you want the girl you're with to be
classy you don't want her doing that but
you'll go look if some other woman's
doing that is that how it works like i
have a friend who's
ridiculously jealous
okay
and he'll say i don't want guys looking
at my chick bro like super jealous like
i don't want what you gonna do i don't
want my girl going out like i go well
let me ask you pose your questions i'm
like so you don't like guys looking at
your chick i go well why do you think
they're looking at your chick because
she's hot bro i go well let me pose a
question would you rather your girl walk
in and people look at her and just like
look the other way or don't even pay
attention because i have something to
tell you buddy that means they don't
find your chick hot at all and she's
unattractive is that what you want from
your girl he's like no i don't want that
either
then i go well then you can't have it
both ways you can't have a beautiful
woman or a hot woman
and then not expect people to look
okay
so go date an ugly fat girl and nobody's
gonna look i promise bro
okay
but
it's like they want their they want the
other guys to want their woman but they
want to be mad when the other guys look
at their woman it's very strange it's
like quite a conundrum jealousy is not a
good uh quality but you want to be able
to at least
trust me is not jealousy can be sexy if
it's like not
crazy you know you want a man who
i would want a man who like
this is my woman you know
hands off you know it's not for you let
me tell you this i know who he's talking
about and it borders on crazy does it
really you know what i'm saying that's
very interesting
i think i do no
if not we know somebody
in common that's like oh that's not who
i'm talking about no one we work with
here but however but look guys have eyes
you know how they say like so do we by
the way okay fair enough
um you know how they say like you've got
two ears and one mouth for a reason
right so like listen more than you talk
you also have two eyes right so like
that's most guys to like breaking news
that's all they want to do they want to
sit here with their girl and they want
to just be able to do this from time to
time
and just like that's all they don't want
to go get that girl's number they're not
trying to sleep with them they're just
trying to acknowledge
i hear you it can be disrespectful i
would imagine have you never seen jeremy
do this
ever when we first started dating i saw
it a couple of times okay perfectly
honest first started dating but i don't
see that at all now because you did you
g-check him
no because you're the type of girl to be
like what the [ __ ] are you no i made a
joke about it i made a joke about it
wearing a knife we're at a restaurant i
got a knife right here
what are you looking at
yes ma'am i made a joke about it and i i
really made a joke because i really felt
like if he was gonna be looking he
should be looking at somebody hotter
than that i didn't i didn't find his
taste to be that good i really i was
like cause you know sometimes i'll look
at a girl i'm not gonna lie i'm not
attracted to women but sometimes and why
are you looking at the girls well
sometimes i'll look at a girl because
sometimes it's not about like hot it's
about like wow what's going on with that
outfit oh that's like a shock can we
just all agree that women are nice to
look at men can be nice guys like not as
not as pretty as women i disagree there
i disagree
if you like the short clip you can catch
another one here or you can catch the
full episode right here